do you guys feel emasculated when you're
cooking and then your girls come around
and starts fing you in the ass only when
I'm washing my clothes I would feel more
emasculated when they wrap around and
go and then you're just like styling up
like and cook
[Music]
right welcome back to another episode of
split the room split the room split the
room split the room wait I've never done
split the room what's that in this
series we're going to go ahead and
present something very divisive that we
are all not going to agree on do we have
to take a side and then they have to
take a side you have to take a side yep
you must take a side how do you know
it's going to be so divisive trust me
you are not going to have the same
opinion on this one wow that's hard cuz
JK group think we got a uh another
lovely prompt from some friends of ours
down under down down
that same gym that has these arguments
in the locker room that uh they were the
ones who uh presented The Prompt that
caused us to split the room when Jesus
was here um they have another thing
they're fighting about okay and I'll
read you what it is exactly they debate
a lot huh they do they have these locker
room debates and then when they can't
come to a consensus they with us okay
we're like the Supreme Court of dumb
feel like locker rooms cuz I feel like
locker rooms they have all these debates
right but then to have an actual group
that will like lay down the law they
have to call us yeah they have to call
the dumbest men on Earth the dumbest men
on Earth this gym this gym is called
jungle all right Jungle Gym o oh I
didn't put that together here we go I'm
going to tell you the short version and
then I'm going to get into some details
okay the short version is is it gay to
have your girl do butt stuff to you yes
no no absolutely it's what split the
room split the room wait which side's
which side's G do we need to run to the
side yeah do do we rearrange ourselves
according to our before you do that
listen to this uh this is what our
friend is asking she said is it gay to
love pegging what's pegging again to
love it someone you give a love it I
think when someone uh is penetrating you
I don't want to Peg anybody cuz I have
my own dick because here's the reason
the reason why they're not agreeing get
the reason is why would it be gay if
it's a girl that's doing it to you I
know why why because she doesn't feel
anything does she have to can she just
oh it's not balanced One Way can she be
a giver she's just exercising I mean
she's feeling something eternally hand
job is also exercising what if it's like
a double penetration thing
oh okay okay oh but lesbians Peg each
other and they're not are they feeling
thank you that's the next thing she said
she said but females can Peg each other
and go home to their boyfriends and not
be lesbians huh wait no no
wait maybe buy then females can Peg each
other and go home to their boyfriends in
what
world
wait not yours apparently my dream world
yeah that sounds like a porn fantasy
they do this in Australia you've never
heard of girls doing stuff with girls
but not being lesbians I've never heard
of girls pegging each other on a [__]
girls night out and then they come home
to their boyfriends ever I never heard
of that
well I'm sure it's a thing yeah it's a
thing when guys write the
story in fan fiction yeah well I missed
out on that [__] colorful part of
life a big part of it is like what is
the dude imagining while he's getting
penetrated I think so too well that's a
great point cuz if if they're thinking
about their secret lover that's a dude
then it's
gay or how hard is that guy biting his
lip if he's biting it really hard you're
already not looking at your girl
right you're already not looking at your
girl cuz you're getting cuz you getting
it you can you can make eye contact
flexibility do you have what the [__] or
I'm just fat missionary what so let's um
let's hear from our let's hear from our
resident gay homie Tyler if my girl is
doing butt stuff to me am I gay
absolutely not cool can you explain it
Tyler can you first first we need to
agree to terms can you define what gay
is for the room yes yeah that's a good
way to start gay means want to do sexual
something sexually with another man two
men doing stuff sexually do you have to
believe in it you have to believe in it
though so
like you to believe it two dud two dudes
in jail right they do it and then they
ask him are you gay and he's like hell
no I ain't gay but they do it physically
oh yeah if they were able to get a heart
on [__] rock
hard% that's why I think it's about
mentality like you can imagine so Tyler
indeed you are in fact proving my point
which is that if a chick is penetrating
my butt with a dick shaped object and
I'm getting hard over it I'm gay no cuz
just the concept emotionally of your
girl doing something that she might be
enjoying also turn you on why would she
be enjoying it she's like doing [__]
cardio girl some girls like that some
girls like that Pelon on my [__] dude
so if I'm having if I'm having sex with
Nick but he identifies as a woman is
that gay ooh that's a different thing
that is a different thing because I
don't know what it is difference okay I
think I think like it I think where this
is getting confusing is the dildo aspect
cuz it's a dick right but what if she
was but it's plastic but what if she was
finger [__] you with her delicate
female hat can you say finger [__]
the same way again what if she was
finger [__] your [__] butthole
yeah okay she hading but she had a very
delicate woman feminine finger yeah
let's go with that one okay that's
different not gay I see that's not g gay
long like not a manicure or any like
long nails like that seems scary having
like a dick shaped object in your butt
and you were really enjoying okay let's
say it's a souvenir Eiffel Tower from
Paris okay that's different that's like
an assumed penis they literally make
those things look like dicks and and
like be like like here here's here's
here's another one I've seen a porno
where girls have a huge assortment of
dildos okay yeah there's a huge segment
of them that are not shaped like di or
they don't look like dick octopus
tentacles yeah yeah yeah they they're
different shapes Stu some of them look
like you could get at a crystal shop yes
what if it was
that at a crystal
shop so
Fierce what if it's that what if it's
not so I'm returning to now logic again
once again and saying that's not gay
because like anal beads right that
doesn't look like a dick that looks like
Boba
looks so does it make you Taiwanese yeah
a big [__] necklace you buy in like
Thailand beads
yeah not not gay not if a strapon is in
in like a conceptual penis supposed to
be a penis and by the way why she got to
have it on her hips yeah why she got to
have it on her hips sometimes it's
around the mouth like dude oh yeah it's
for it's for leverage boobs likee for
her to act like a man for leverage about
this Steve she has a strap on pcking
from the back she stepping on your but
she also reaches around and she's
jacking you off oh that sounds fun is
that gay it's more talented first of all
B was already gay from like the part
where she's [__] me so I don't know
what the reachon does but she's a girl
she's a multitasker wait wait wait how
about this she's wearing a strap on but
she's not using it she's just still
finger [__] your [__] not not not
what if she has a strap on and she just
skull [__] you dude n uh that's kind
of gay that's kind of gay I think that
might be more gay than is I think I
think if there's eye contact it's not
gay yeah dude there's no eye contact
than the dude's imagining something see
I think we're thinking about this wrong
cuz if she's wearing a strap on she's
pegging you from the back it is gay
but in that sense gay is okay whose
choice is it though that sense wait hear
me out that's
specific what does that mean you're
honored only in that
sense what if it was her request and he
was just doing it out of love oh that's
love and then she just wants dominance
well dude it's out of love but he's gay
that's isn't that probably what it was
in the first place if this has happened
you were cute
a that's gay quote
and I meant that in a very gay
way I just think that if if it's a strap
on it's gay but if it's not and it's
like some kind of finger butt play St
like Joe's not Joe's not gay my client
is not
gay just cuz he likes hookers eating I
have I have another scenario for you
Steve this is plan on your logic so I
can better understand okay thank you if
your girlfriend has a strap on [__] you
in the ass that's gay yes right let's
say you and your best guy guy friend he
has a strap on vagina and do you [__]
his strap on vagina is that straight but
is the vagina right here at the [__]
answer me that steeve wait are you
saying is his is his dick straight or is
it I don't know you he has a strap on
vagina and you're now you have two dudes
smashing pelvises are they making eye
contact can can the court confirm that a
strapon vagina even exists let's see
that's the Gest thing that's been so
far the you can buy in [__] the a
[__] that's true exhibit a no way wow
exhibit V exhibit exhibit V exhibit v
wait can we see it in the profile please
they actually make that [__] wait that's
for man wait where can you where can you
purchase this does have my color send me
that what the wait wait wait so wait
that barely looks like a vagina this is
gay that looks like a baseball C this
gay wait I'll tell you why this is gay
are they sell that in Target no they're
saying they s played against Sports I
think it's it's at Hobby Lobby this is
gay because because you're basically
lining that up with your buddy's
butthole are you not yeah are you not
but that's so both ways are gay what is
it both ways are how far out does that
come that's what I'm saying I see what I
see what B's saying this is true then if
you flip it it should be the other way
if your friend if your friend does this
and you start [__] it that's kind of
gay I think it's gay that's what I'm
saying it's gay Tyler what are you
saying so why are we avoiding being gay
wait we are straight on this
side
if if if your wife came to you and she
was like I want to [__] you with the
strap on them cheeks would you would say
no because that's gay oh I'd say hey
[__] I've been trying to [__] your ass
forever you're not getting anything from
me just real stories just real
frustrations there are there I remember
there are people who believe that doing
anal sex on your girl was gay what I
mean
yeah so are people against being gay or
just
anal is this your friend MO again no no
no I
thinka I think what it is is it's like
they're not saying that it's literally
gay but it's a gay act that's crazy put
it in a butt so going back to what I
said what if that is considered gay why
are you avoiding being gay yeah yeah Joe
why are you voiding it if you're on the
straight side that's one of the scariest
things you could ever be if you're
straight tribe in this sense Gay's okay
you know Gay's okay all what if what if
she's wearing a dildo but it's not in
the shape of penis it's a finger huh and
then they're using the she must be
handless [__] the [__] out of you blow
it all up blow it all up so she's saying
that uh I guess the example that that
they the girls were making about women
pegging each other and then not
automatically be the dream scenario that
never happens yeah she's saying that
like that made a lot of the straight
guys in the conversation go
oh I guess it's not gay then no it is
you know why cuz lesbians are fake gay
exactly all lesbians they're all you
know why cuz think about it they need
male parts to have sex still a dildo is
a male
part where guys they could just [__] the
butt in the mouth all good yeah we could
even get two dicks together it's a and
do a handshake from what I understand in
most lesbians it's not dicks they have a
problem with it's everything around the
dick
yeah Joe but they're still using male
parts like dildos and things they just
use us so that's to that's to me more by
than straight
lesbies so I am so conf I don't even
know where we're at right now any real
lesbian Nick do you agree lesbianism is
just a complete fetish and a complete
fabrication I don't think so dude I
think they're gay too dude I've seen
some Les then why do they need to use
guy body parts in their party time H cuz
I think there's a double standard across
the board no like you know there's
double standards from gay guys aren't
putting vagina strapons on why do they
make they should you know what cuz they
come built in cuz they come built in
dude they come built in 10 that's true
they come prepack prepackage bars you
know what I mean the ladies they don't
got anything built in so in her example
right she's like well we could use
[__] strap-ons and we're not gay and
I'm like that it wait it is though isn't
it can girls make out with each other
and still go home to their boyfriends
like yeah it's fine yeah the scenario
should should they
move I think that's fine that double
standard is is it's one-sided so it's
not for sure a double standard it's the
the ratio is off right if girls are
making out that's a guy's fantasy you
guys if guys are making out that's just
gay I don't even know we're arguing
anymore honestly how do you feel about
two chicks that make out and but then
you know they have boyfriends like how
do you view that do you view them as
just like you guys are just [__]
around I just think they're having fun
like not everything has to be about a
long deep sexual desire I agree with
that girls just being girls it's not gay
they're just having fun so two guys just
making out just having fun yeah we did
that earlier we did it earlier that
pretty sure that happened ear we were
kissy we were kiss I will say we were
kissy boys earlier we were kissy boys
and that was gay and that was okay f it
was vessel with the boys yeah best with
the boys it's a segment it's part of the
show hey best with the boys shirt that's
how we start every shoot day from now on
I'm just saying it was gay and it's okay
it's not gay it's just it's just team
city was just but the moment no gay is a
spectrum was about the moment there's a
little bit gay and then there's super
gay that's true okay we're on this side
there's a spectrum we're on the low
volume part just so you know cuz if all
right if two straight girls made out
passionately for fun right to me that's
a that's a gay act but they're Straight
girls yeah it's a party trick it's a fun
party trick we need to be wearing suits
for this segment by the way what does
that even mean it's such a mistake that
we're not just for I do can I do a gay
Act without committing to being
classified yes like what what can I do
so so so for example passionately by the
way so for example there's a term called
men that have sex with men yeah and that
means they're not gay cuz they're not
romantically attracted to men or
anything like that they just like the
physical feeling yeah and to me that's
like that just Tyler what the heck is
that that is fair you can have sex with
a man one time and not be considered gay
right I think we actually sounds pretty
gay to me but that's the termin no
because the concept is Happ is that a
real thing yeah if you cook one meal
you're not a chef no but we're talking
about a regular thing so men that have
sex with men is that just gay or can you
be straight and be man that have sex
with I mean first off I'm kind of in the
belief set that you don't have to label
things super hardcore but if you were
going to label it uh why are you having
sex with a
dude it kind of goes back to does it it
goes back I like the Simplicity of that
it's very simple yeah and by the way in
the gay community right they all the
time gay guys talk about the straight
guys quote unquote who are like sucking
dick or whatever and they're insisting
they're not gay but guess what they're
gay and they all know they're gay so
like why are we pretending here that
it's not gay to get drilled in the butt
even if it's a chick she's Drilling in
we're taking back to the chicks again
yeah no no but gay is a spectrum with a
gay with a with a strap-on [__] shaped
object if you're getting railed in the
[__] you're gay yeah and you're
imagining Cal Drago and your Daenerys
getting [__] I don't think gay is the
right term for that I think that would
just be likes to be pegged I think
that's a separate cat like as you're I
think you're grouping something into
like the wrong group kind of especially
if it's a chick you know I think from my
experience it's not that gay I don't
think cuz if it's the chick that's
straight yeah they have nice hands means
that he's like for Domination yeah dude
if they're [__] Ah that's a good one
that is true because some people get off
on like an innocent girl that does
something out of character like very
sexually deviant and hardcore and then
you know you're you're a [__]
powerful CEO and you're just like I just
can't wait till I go home and put a
choke collar on and have her drip candle
wax on my butt yeah didn't you guys say
that's what Anthony likes yeah whoa as a
CEO
he has a ball gag in his mouth
financially Domina the candle wax like
all goes inside the hole no it has
nothing to do with it but then the high
heels come on and his balls get crushed
yeah he like getting stepped on that has
nothing to do with any of this yeah
you're right it's not g up this is
Anthony's thing but then on top of that
if you like humiliation what if you want
to get pegged in the booty hole exactly
and that's not it's still see that's
where these guys had a change of heart
is say initially we're saying changes of
hearts are gay anything touching the
butt Tyler said yeah he said yeah
that anything touching the butt is gay
they originally that's originally what
but it's a woman touching a bed that's
what they originally said they ended up
saying later that oh I guess it's not
I'll say this bro when my girl is trying
to stick her fingers in my ass I feel a
little gay but then I realize it's not
that gay at all how often does she try
that almost every day is she doing it
for fun she's doing it for fun cuz I
know what are you doing it for though
being playful what's your motivation my
motivation is uh to not let her do it so
I just try to run away so it's like a
cat and mouse ongoing yeah yeah but I
know here's the my problem with it is
like when she puts her fingers in my
butt I know she she has no serious
intentions she's not really trying to
get in there yeah she's not really
trying to to motorboat that thing she
got she got small fingers got long
fingers o she got Daddy Long Leg fingers
and
long it's like playing with an automatic
door at a supermarket but you don't need
anything in there she got Richardson
Nails yeah do you guys feel emasculated
when you're cooking and then your girls
come around and starts [__] you in
the ass what no I don't only when I'm
washing my clothes I would feel more
emasculated when they wrap around they
go and then you're just like stop I
can't [__] cook
right those are some bomb ass eggs I bet
I wish Tiff did that more but she
doesn't she doesn't do it enough is that
how your stove gotle [__]
freakier girl you wish Tim was more D
yeah yeah I wish it was more D
interesting yeah so I guess in that
sense if you were into domination in bed
if it's a girl that's administering it
it's not necessarily a changing
sexuality it's just doing what you like
right just switching rolles dude some
straight men are just submissive little
[__] there you go I will give you
that I think that's a compelling
argument that I did I did not see
initially that I agree with how about
this I got one more I got one more okay
so let's say so we've established guy
bent over girl has strap on bone in the
dude not gay just likes to be dominated
right let's say guy turns around still
the same players in the game guy turns
around girl has a strap on guy Now sucks
off the strap on [__] is that gay or is
that what is that is that
magic yeah that's magic I think it's
called that's magic that's very
questionable for sure depends on the
intention reframe it reframe it how is
that not
gay that's a good question I I have a
better hypothetical okay go hit it okay
dudes jerking off together watching
straight porn gay that's what he did
it's called a circle jerk I've done that
with my brother I think that's straight
gay gay we got him boys we got him we
[__] got him it wasn't gay we made
eye contact now we got three gay dudes
in the room dude I'm not jerking off
near any dude
ever you can't survive in
prison